the most important question great
salespeople ask themselves is the
following if I were them would I buy
this product whatever the product is let
me say it again if I were them the
customer would I buy this product now
let me tell why that's a very important
question to ask because if the answer is
yes you're no longer selling you're just
telling your advising you're an adviser
your friend your brother you're sitting
hey John this is what I would do if I
were you let me tell you why
boom boom boom this is what I would do
if I were you
boom boom boom it becomes a very easy
sell to make it becomes tough whenever
you're selling a product and you're
sitting there trying to convince
yourself to feel good and not feel
guilty about a product you're selling
the other person that's a difficult
thing to do for too long the time so the
key to sales is very simple if you can
get to the point where you can answer
that question and answer very
comfortably
you will take your closing percentage
from 20 30 40 50 percent to 70 80 90 %
at a time simply because you are so
comfortable and confident selling a
product to the other person that you
would buy yourself if you were them
[Music]
you